today our country our people this house
are united in mourning
Queen Elizabeth II was this great
country's greatest monarch
and for the vast majority of us it feels
impossible to imagine a Britain without
her
all our thoughts are with her beloved
family our royal family
at this moment of profound grief
this is a deep and private loss for them
yet it's one we all share
because Queen Elizabeth created a
special personal relationship with us
all
that relationship was built on the
attributes
that defined her reign
her total commitment to service and Duty
her deep Devotion to the country the
Commonwealth
and the people she loved
in return for that
we loved her
and it is because of that great shared
love
that we grieve today
for the 70 glorious years of her Reign
Our Queen was at the heart of this
nation's life
she did not simply Reign Over Us
she lived alongside us
she shared in our hopes and our fears
our joy and our pain
our good times and our bad
Our Queen played a crucial role as the
thread between the history we cherish
and the present we own
a reminder that our generational battle
against the evil of fascism
or the emergence of a New Britain out of
the rubble of the second world war do
not only belong to the Past
but are the inheritance of each and
every one of us
a reminder that the creativity the hard
work the Enterprise that has always
defined this nation is as abundant now
as it ever was
a reminder that the prospect of a better
future still Burns brightly
never was this link more important
that when our country was plunged into
lockdown at the start of the pandemic
her simple message
that we would see family again
that we would see friends again
that we would be together again
gave people strength and courage when
they needed it most
but it wasn't simply the message that
allowed a shaken Nation to draw upon
those Reserves
it was the fact that she was the
messenger
covid closed the front doors of every
home in the country it made our lives
smaller and more remote
but she was able to reach beyond that to
reassure us and steal us
at the time we were most alone
but a time we'd been driven apart
she held the nation close
in a way no one else could have done
for that
we say thank you
on the occasion of the queen Silver
Jubilee in 1977.
Philip Larkin wrote of her reign
in times where nothing stood but
worsened or grew strange
there was one constant good
she did not change
it feels like we're once again in a
moment in our history where as Larkin
put it
things are growing strange
everything is spinning a nation requires
a Still Point
when times are difficult
it requires comfort
and when direction is hard to find it
requires leadership
the loss of our Queen robs this country
of its stillest point
its greatest Comfort at precisely the
time we need those things most
but our Queen's commitment to us
her life of public service was
underpinned by one crucial understanding
that the country she came to symbolize
is bigger than any one individual or any
one Institution
it is the sum total of all our history
and all our endeavors
and it will endure
the late Queen would have wanted us to
redouble our efforts to turn our cholera
and face the storm
to carry on
most of all she would want us to
remember that it is in these moments
that we must pull together
this house is a place where ideas and
ideals are debated of course that leads
to passionate disagreement of course
temperatures can run High
but we all do it
in pursuit of something greater
we do it because we believe we can make
this great country and its people
greater still
at this moment of uncertainty
where our country feels caught between a
past it cannot relive
and a future yet to be revealed
we must always remember one of the great
lessons of our Queen's reign
that we are always better
when we rise above the petty the trivial
the day-to-day
to focus on the things that really
matter the things that unite us
rather than those which divide us
our Elizabethan age may now be over
but her Legacy will live on forever
and as the children of that era it falls
upon us to take that Legacy forward
to show the same love of country the
love of one another
as she did
to show empathy and compassion as she
did
and to get Britain through this dark
night and bring it into the dawn
as she did
we joined together today not just to say
goodbye to our Queen
but to say something else important
God Save the King
because as one era ends
so another begins
King Charles III has been a devoted
servant of this country his entire life
he has been a powerful voice for
fairness and understood the importance
of the environment long before many
others
as he ascends to his new role with the
queen consort by his side
the whole house
indeed the whole country
will join today to wish him a long happy
and successful reign
speaker the emotions we see Across the
Nation today
are echoed across the Commonwealth to
which Our Queen was so committed
in the church to which Our Queen was so
devoted
and in the armed forces which she led
and her family served
around the world people will be United
in mourning for her passing
and United in celebrating her life
we've already seen beautiful tributes
flow from across the world it will be
impossible to capture them all here
but each one as a reminder of the esteem
in which she was held
of what she achieved on behalf of her
country
of the shared values we treasure
the reason our lost feels so profound
is not just because she stood at the
head of our country for 70 years
but because in spirit
she stood amongst us
as we move forward
as we Forge A New Path as we build
towards a better future
she will always be with us
for all she gave us and all she will
continue to give us
we say thank you
May Our Queen rest in peace
God Save the King
[Music]